This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So I'm down at the bottom of the hill away from the highway and I'm about to cross a really old railroad bridge, not an active railroad anymore. That's Jack Roteliko wandering around the New Hampshire woods. It's a pretty view. He's about 10 miles north of the state capital of the interstate 93. In a pretty out-of-the-way place, there are no signs or markers on the road indicating something special is there, but he's found something. So if you get out to this little island and the railroad tracks go straight across, but what you really notice is this epic looking granite monument in the middle of the island?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我现在正走在远离高速公路的山脚下，准备穿过一座非常古老的铁路桥，这条铁路现在已经废弃了。那是杰克·罗特利科（Jack Roteliko）在新罕布尔州的树林里闲逛。风景很美。他位于州首府以北约 10 英里、93 号州际公路旁。在一个相当偏僻的地方，路边没有任何标志或路标表明那里有什么特殊的东西，但他确实找到了一个地方。如果你走到这个小岛上，铁轨直穿而过，但你真正注意到的是岛中央这座看起来极其宏伟的花岗岩纪念碑？
It looks a lot like a monument you'd see in a city park, except it's on a forested island in the middle of a river. It is enormous. It's 30 feet tall. Wow. It's all granite and on top of a tall pedestal there's a woman. She's wearing this gown that's falling off her shoulders. In her right hand she has a tomhawk and in her left hand she has a fistful of scouts. And on the back of this thing, I'm going to run around to the back here. Is the inscription. Now let's pause for just a second here.
它看起来很像你在城市公园里看到的纪念碑，除了它是位于河中央的一个长满树木的岛屿上。它非常巨大。它有 30 英尺高。哇。它全是由花岗岩建造的，在高高的基座顶部有一个女人。她穿着一件从肩膀上滑落的长袍。她右手拿着一把战斧，左手抓着一把头皮。在这东西的背面，我要跑到背面去。是碑文。现在我们暂停一小会儿。
If you are a regular listener to the show, you know how I feel about plaques and always reading them. The reason being that plaques tell stories, sometimes they tell really amazing stories, if you can decipher them. March 15th, 30th, 1697. The Warhoop, Tomahawk, Faggot, and Infanticides were at Haverill. The ashes of wigwam campfires at night and of ten of the tribe are here. I got nothing from that.
如果你是这个节目的忠实听众，你就会知道我对牌匾以及总是阅读它们的感受。原因是因为牌匾会讲述故事，如果你能破译它们，有时它们会讲述非常精彩的故事。1697年3月15日、30日。在黑弗里尔（Haverhill）发生了战吼、战斧、柴捆和杀婴事件。威格旺（wigwam）营地夜晚的灰烬和部落中十个人的灰烬都在这里。我从中学不到什么。
Yeah, not a lot of detail there. Honestly, the whole island was strange to me. Kind of creepy, actually. Not very well kept up, this enormous imposing statue with the eerie plaque, the scalps? What's crazy is this statue was erected in 1874, making it the oldest monument dedicated to a woman in the US. So you think someone would come out here and at least mow the grass, you know? Well, what I learned is that plaque does tell a story, though not an obvious one, and I learned there's a good reason why the grounds
是的，没有太多细节。老实说，整个岛对我都感觉很奇怪。实际上有点诡异。维护得不是很好，这个巨大且气势汹汹的雕像配上诡异的牌匾，还有头皮？疯狂的是，这座雕像建于 1874 年，使其成为美国历史最悠久的专为女性而建的纪念碑。所以你会认为会有人来这里至少修剪一下草坪，对吧？好吧，我了解到那块牌匾确实讲述了一个故事，尽管不是一个显而易见的故事，而且我了解到场地被忽视是有原因的。
are neglected. In fact, what to do with this historic site has become a bit of a problem. And it all has to do with the woman in the monument and what she did. The story starts about 50 miles south of the monument in a town called Haverall, Massachusetts. I went down there and met up with a local historian named Tom Spitaleri in the parking lot of a Dunkin Donuts.
事实上，如何处理这个历史遗址已经成为一个有点棘手的问题。这一切都与纪念碑里的那个女人以及她所做的事有关。故事从纪念碑以南约 50 英里处一个叫做马萨诸塞州黑弗里尔（Haverall）的小镇开始。我去了那里，在一个唐恩都乐（Dunkin Donuts）的停车场遇到了一位名叫汤姆·斯皮塔莱里（Tom Spitaleri）的当地历史学家。
How you doing? Good. Jack. Tom, nice to meet you too. Tom is a die hard New Englander. I'll tell you he's wearing a Boston Red Sox jacket. On top of a Boston Celtics jersey, on top of a Boston Celtics jersey on top of a New England Patriots t-shirt. The guy's going to get a little noisy. It needs a lot of work. Sure. And everywhere we drive in Haverl, Tom sees signs of New England's past, particularly
你好吗？很好。杰克。汤姆，很高兴认识你。汤姆是一个地道的新英格兰人。我告诉你，他穿着一件波士顿红袜队的夹克。套在波士顿凯尔特人队的球衣外面，再套在另一件波士顿凯尔特人队的球衣外面，外面又套着一件新英格兰爱国者队的T恤。这家伙可能会变得有点吵闹。这需要做很多工作。当然。我们在黑弗里尔开车的每个地方，汤姆都能看到新英格兰过去的痕迹，尤其是殖民时期的痕迹。
from colonial times. And to the time of Hannah Dustin. During that time, we're embroiled in what some historians are now calling World War One. Most people would know it as the French Indian law, or King Phillips, King George's, and the Seven Years' War. In the 1600s, New England was a war zone between the French, the British, and the Native Americans. By the end of that century, disease and war would wipe out most Native Americans in the Northeast.
以及汉娜·达斯廷（Hannah Dustin）的时代。在那期间，我们卷入了现在一些历史学家称之为第一次世界大战的冲突中。大多数人会称之为法印战争，或者菲利普国王战争、乔治国王战争和七年战争。在 1600 年代，新英格兰是法国人、英国人和美洲原住民之间的战区。到了那世纪末，疾病和战争几乎消灭了东北部的所有美洲原住民。
And Havrell was, The Wild West. I mean, it sounds funny, but putting it in today's contents is what it was. We were the outpost. There was nothing north of us. That was it. There was nothing but wilderness around, making it an easy target for attacks by Native Americans. Bands of Native Americans had shifting alliances with the British and the French. The French paid abanakis to abduct Brits and bring them to Quebec. Then the French would sell these captives back to the British. It was a slave trade.
黑弗里尔当时就是美国旧西部。我的意思是，这听起来很有趣，但把它放在今天的背景下看，它确实就是那样。我们当时就是前哨站。我们的北方空无一物。就是这样。周围除了荒野别无他物，这使其成为美洲原住民袭击的易攻击目标。一帮帮美洲原住民与英国人和法国人有着不断变化的联盟关系。法国人付钱给阿纳基人（Abanakis），让他们绑架英国人并把他们带到魁北克。然后法国人会把这些俘虏卖回给英国人。这是一场奴隶贸易。
So I mean, this area was constantly being rated. Constantly. In 1697, a woman named Hannah Dustin was recovering from delivering her eighth child when Abanaki's raided haverl. They killed and captured dozens of colonists and burned buildings. That's what the word of Faggot's on the monument refers to. A Faggot was a bundle of sticks used to fuel the fire. During the raid, Hannah Dustin's husband was outside with seven of their kids, defending
所以我的意思是，这个地区不断遭到袭击。不断地。1697年，一个名叫汉娜·达斯廷的女人在生下她的第八个孩子后正在康复，当时阿纳基人袭击了黑弗里尔。他们杀死并俘虏了数十名殖民者并烧毁了建筑物。这就是纪念碑上“柴捆”（Faggots）一词所指的意思。柴捆是一捆用来生火的木柴。在袭击期间，汉娜·达斯廷的丈夫和他们的七个孩子在外面，保卫着家园和他的孩子，但阿纳基人闯入屋里，绑架了汉娜、她刚出生的女婴以及她的护士玛丽·内夫（Mary Nath）。俘虏们被押送着向北穿过荒野，在离开黑弗里尔不久后，当汉娜的婴儿哭个不停时，其中一个阿纳基人把婴儿砸在树上。这就是纪念碑牌匾上“杀婴”（infanticide）一词的来源。他们继续向北走。他们很可能是前往圣弗朗西斯（St. Francis）前哨站。那在魁北克。在某个时候，这支作战部队将汉娜·达斯廷和玛丽·内夫交给了另一群阿纳基人，一个由几户家庭组成的群体。她作为奴隶被卖给了那些美洲原住民。
the homestead and his children, but Abanakis entered the house, and abducted Hannah, her newborn baby girl, and her nurse, Mary Nath. The captives were marched north through the wilderness, and shortly after leaving Haverl, when Hannah's baby wouldn't stop crying, one of the Abanakis smashed it against the tree. That's where you get the word, infanticide, from the Monuments plaque. They kept walking north. Most likely they were heading to the outpost of St. Francis. That's up in Quebec. At some point the war party handed Hannah Dustin and Mary
所以最后抓走汉娜的那群阿纳基人由两个父亲、两个母亲、一个祖母和一群孩子组成。他们身边已经有一个白人男孩，一个名叫塞缪尔·伦纳德森（Samuel Leonardson）的孩子，他前一年从伍斯特（Worcester）被绑架。所以这总共是三个白人俘虏和十二个阿纳基人。整个队伍穿过梅里马克河（Mary Mac River）来到那个现在建有纪念碑的岛上，他们在那里安营扎寨过夜。
Neff to another group of Abonakis, a group made up of a couple families. She was sold to those Native Americans as a slave. So the group of Abonakis that ended up with Hannah was made up of two fathers, two mothers, a grandmother, and a bunch of children. And they already had a white boy with them, a kid named Samuel Leonardson, who had been abducted from Worcester the previous year. So that makes three white captives and twelve Abanakis. The whole crew crossed the Mary Mac River to the island, the one that now has the monument on it, and they set up camp for the night. Mac River to the island, the one that now has the monument on it, and they set up camp for the night.
在半夜，汉娜·达斯廷做出一个决定。她召集了玛丽和塞缪尔，带领他们绕过熟睡的阿纳基人。他们一个接一个地将战斧砍向阿纳基人的头部。他们总共杀了十个人，两个男人、两个女人、六个孩子，然后在逃跑之前，他们剥下了每个受害者的头皮。有两个阿纳基人活着逃脱了。受伤的老妇和一个小男孩。汉娜、玛丽和塞缪尔乘独木舟离开该岛。一年中这个时候在河上航行是很危险的。河面上肯定塞满了冰块，到处都是急流。他们夜间出行以避免被发现。在消失 15 天后，汉娜·达斯廷和她的同伴在黑弗里尔登陆，震惊了她的丈夫、七个孩子以及所有在袭击中失去过亲人的人。
In the middle of the night, Hannah Dustin made a decision. She rallied Mary and Samuel and led them around the sleeping abanakis. One at a time, they brought a hatchet down on the abanakis heads. They killed ten in total, two men, two women, six children, and then before making their getaway, they scalped each victim. Two abineckis made it out alive. The old woman who was injured and a little boy. Hannah, Mary, and Samuel left the island in a canoe. It was a dangerous time of year to be on the river. It would have been choked with ice and full of rapids. They traveled at night to avoid being seen." In 15 days after vanishing, Hannah Dustin and her companions landed in Haveral,
汉娜·达斯廷就是这座纪念碑上所纪念的女性。她在雕像中拿着的头皮属于她和同伴在岛上杀死的 10 个人，其中包括 6 名儿童。这座雕像并不是新英格兰唯一的汉娜·达斯廷地标，远非如此。还有其他的，特别是在她生活的黑弗里尔。汤姆·斯皮塔莱里带我进行了参观。让我在这里快速靠边停车。只是一个汉娜·达斯廷休息区。
to the total shock of her husband or seven children and everyone who ever lost a family member to a raid. Hannah Dustin is the woman memorialized in the monument. The scalps she is holding in the statue belong to the 10 people, including six children, that she and her companions killed on the island. And that statue isn't the only Hannah Dustin Landmark in New England, not by a long shot. There are others, particularly in Haverl, where she lived. Tom Spitaleri took me on a tour. Let me just pull off here real quick. Just a hand of dust in the rest area.
内夫（deft）名字。这是这条街吗？是的，我总是忘记。就是这里。这是汉娜·达斯廷街。汉娜·达斯廷疗养院。显然，名字叫内夫。现在我们在汉娜·达斯廷岩石处。纪念碑街的名字来源于那里为汉娜·达斯廷建立的纪念碑。
Name deft. Is this the street? Yeah, I always forget. This is it here. Here's hand of dust in street. The hand of dust in nursing home. Obviously, name deft. Now we're at the hand of dust in rock. Monument street got its name from the monument that's there for hand of dust.
博斯科大道（Bosco and Avenue）。博斯科是新罕布什尔州的一个城镇，那个岛就在那里。汤姆甚至带我去了旧加里森房屋（garrison house），本质上是一座堡垒，汉娜·达斯廷在被俘后曾住在那里。我们在里面提供私人玩具。在玻璃柜里是一件我在易趣（eBay）上看到的汉娜·达斯廷纪念品。
Bosco and Avenue. Bosco is the town in New Hampshire, where the island is. Tom even took me to an old garrison house, a fort essentially, where Hannah Duster lived after her captivity. We do private toys in here. In a glass case is a piece of Hannah Duster and memorabilia I've seen on eBay.
在 20 世纪 70 年代，新罕布什尔州委托金宾（Jim Beam）制作了一个汉娜·达斯廷威士忌酒瓶。它是新罕布什尔州雕像的精确复制品，连她手里的血淋淋小头皮都还原了。它是瓷制的。瓷制的。是的，掉到地上就再见晚安了。这有点性感和挑逗，对吧？
In the 1970s, the state of New Hampshire commissioned Jim Beam to make a Hanodustin whiskey decanter. It's an exact replica of the statue in New Hampshire down to the little bloody scalps in her hand. It's made of porcelain. Porcelain. Yeah, that hits the floor goodbye goodnight. It's kind of sexy and provocative, right?
我的意思是，她的事业线突显出来。是的，这在 1697 年是绝对不会发生的。但你还记得，这是在 1976 年，他们做了这个。1976年，这全关乎销售。你是在用一个手里拿着头皮和战斧的性感女人来推销酒。没错，我们甚至不知道她真正的长相，因为没有她的照片。那个威士忌酒瓶可以追溯到 1976 年，
I mean, she's got cleavage popping out. Yeah, that would never have happened back in 1697. But you remember, this was in 1976, they did this. 1976, it was about selling. You're selling booze with a sexy woman with scalps and an axon her hand. Right, and we don't even know what you really looked like because there is no photographs of her. That whiskey decanter is from 1976,
但新罕布什尔历史学会（New Hampshire Historical Society）的博物馆商店里仍然在出售汉娜·达斯廷摇头娃娃。在这个摇头娃娃的底座上写着：“母亲的复仇”。你大概能看出这些低俗的收藏品为什么会让人觉得被冒犯。事实上，对于那些了解整个故事的人来说，所有关于汉娜·达斯廷的东西和地标都是一个问题。
but the New Hampshire Historical Society still sells a Hannah Dustin bobble head in its museum shop. On the base of that bobble head, it says, quote, the mother's revenge. You can probably see how these kitschy collector's items might feel offensive. In fact, all the hand-adustant stuff and hand-adustant landmarks are a problem for some people who know the whole story.
但整个故事，这是一个很难确定的事情。你要理解关于汉娜·达斯廷故事的一些事情。那里有很多不同的解读，也有很多口耳相传的民间传说。汉娜·达斯廷的绑架和逃生发生在 300 多年前，这个故事被讲述和重新讲述了很多次，事实上，我们今天能知道任何关于它的事情，都与她剥了受害者头皮这一事实有关。汉娜回家后，她的丈夫带着她和所有那些阿纳基人的头皮去波士顿出售。
But the whole story, that's a tricky thing to pin down. You get to understand something with the hand-adustant story. There's a lot of interpretation out there, and there's a lot of new and folk law. interpretation out there and there's a lot of knowingly folklore. Hannah Dessons kidnapping and escape happened more than 300 years ago and the story has been told and re-told a lot and actually the reason we know anything about it today has to do with the fact that she scalped her victims. After Hannah came home, her husband took her and all those abanaki scalps down to Boston to sell them.
如果你像我一样，当你听说她剥了受害者的头皮时，你可能以为她有什么嗜血狂。我以为剥头皮是部落对白人做的事，而不是反过来。事实证明我大错特错了。殖民地政府为美洲原住民的头皮、头颅甚至手支付现金。他们对男人的头皮支付最多，对女人较少，对孩子最少。他们甚至会为了不同派系之间的冲突，向某些美洲原住民支付其他美洲原住民身体部位的费用。
Now, if you're like me, when you heard she had scalped her victims, you may have thought she had some kind of bloodlust. I thought scalping with something tribes did to white people, not the other way around. Turns out I was very, very wrong. Colonial governments paid cash for Native American scalouts, heads, and even hands. They would pay most for a man, less for a woman, and least for a child. They would even pay Native Americans for the body parts of other Native Americans, depending on who was worrying with whom at the time.
所以达斯廷剥受害者头皮是有经济激励的。但这就是我们今天依然知道这个故事的原因。当汉娜在波士顿出售她的头皮时，她坐下来和科顿·马瑟（Cotton Mathur）交谈，后者写下了她的故事。他的名字你可能听过。科顿·马瑟是新英格兰新教教会的领袖。他与塞勒姆审巫案有联系，他是一个严厉、末日审判式的牧师，四处旅行发表布道。科顿·马瑟访问的这些小边境城镇。里面挤满了那些由于美洲原住民袭击而失去亲人的惊魂未定的殖民者。马瑟一次又一次地向狂热的教堂信徒讲述达斯廷的故事，从而树立了达斯廷作为女英雄的地位。
So Dustin had financial incentive for scalping her victims. But here's the reason we still know the story. When Hannah was in Boston selling her scouts, she sat down with Cotton Mathur, and he wrote her story down. His name might ring a bell. Cotton Mathur was head of the Protestant church in New England. He had ties to the Salem witch trials, and he was a fire and brimstone minister
嗯，我认为汉娜·达斯廷的故事之所以能够流传这么久，是因为它不仅仅是一个关于一个杀人女人的故事。它实际上已经成为了在不同历史时期关于美洲民族的故事。这是巴巴拉·卡特（Barbara Cutter），北爱荷华大学的历史学家和教授。这是一个关于 17 世纪殖民地与美洲原住民战斗的故事。这是一个为 19 世纪美国向西扩张辩护的故事。而在最近几年，它在本土上被用作关于文化战争的故事，真的。
who traveled around giving sermons. These little frontier towns at Cotton Mathur visited. They were filled with these shell-shot colonists who had missing family members from Native American raids. Mother told Dustin's story again and again to rap churchgoers building Dustin's status as a heroine. Well, I think the Hannah Dustin story has endured for so long because it's not just a story about a woman who killed people.
卡特研究了汉娜·达斯廷纪念碑是如何以及为什么被建造的。她说，当......我偶然在一份 1890 年代盐湖城摩门教女性报纸上看到一篇文章，文章开篇就说“谁没听说过汉娜·达斯廷呢”时，她真正深刻体会到了这个故事传播得有多远。我的意思是，汉娜·达斯廷来自马萨诸塞州。被俘后，汉娜·达斯廷在殖民地的默默无闻中生活。她实际上又生了七个孩子，并在 84 岁时去世。在整个 1700 年代没有人谈论她。她被遗忘了。直到……
It actually has become a story about the American nation at different points in time. This is Barbara Cutter, historian and professor at the University of Northern Iowa. It was a story about the colonial battle against Native Americans in the 17th century. It was a story justifying the westward expansion of the United States in the 19th century. And in more recent years, it has been used as a story domestically about culture wars, really. Cutter has researched how and why the hand-adjusted monuments were built. And she says it really hit home just how far the story had traveled when... I happened across a Salt Lake City Mormon woman's newspaper in the 1890s that started off
在 1810 年代和 1820 年代，美国是一个新国家，那时的许多知识分子试图创造一种独特的美国文化。因此，他们开始讲述美国故事，并试图发掘美国的英雄和女英雄。于是国家的文学精英们四处搜寻一些好的美国老故事，他们找到了汉娜·达斯廷。卡特说，如果你是一个美国人，比如说在 1865 年，好吧，你最有可能第一次遇到她的地方是在你打开学校的美国历史教科书时。
by saying, who has not heard of Hanodustin? I mean, Hanodustin was from Massachusetts. After her captivity, Hanodust Dustin lived in colonial obscurity. She actually had seven more kids and died at age 84. No one talked about her through the 1700s. She was forgotten. Until... In the 18 teens and the 1820s, the United States was a new nation and a lot of intellectuals at that point in time were trying to create a
如果你阅读霍桑（Hawthorne）等著名美国作家的作品，你也会遇到她的故事。或者约翰·格林利夫·惠蒂尔（John Greenleaf Whittier）或亨利·戴维·梭罗（Henry David Thoreau）、流行杂志、报纸、散文集、儿童读物、绘画。在 19 世纪，汉娜·达斯廷是个家喻户晓的名字。强尼·苹果籽（Johnny Appleseed）、大卫·克罗基特（Davey Crockett）、汉娜·达斯廷。但随着每一次故事的重述，事情发生了变化。人们为了适应自己的目的而改变了叙事。
distinctly American culture. And so they started telling American stories and trying to uncover American heroes and heroines. So the country's literary elite dug around for some good old American stories and they found Hannah Dustin. Cutter says if you were an American in, say, 1865, Well, the first place you might likely come across her would be when you opened your American history textbook in the school.
对于杀害了儿童的美国人来说，达斯廷杀害儿童成了一个道德问题，尤其是考虑到他们不仅是儿童，而且是睡着的儿童。作家们省略了细节，美化了其他细节，有时甚至凭空捏造事情。他们完全漏掉了她杀死的儿童，用战士取而代之，那个逃脱的阿纳基儿童，作家们说达斯廷是故意放过他的，但这没有任何证据。大多数作家将汉娜·达斯廷描绘成一个富有同情心的女英雄，一个寻求正当复仇的愤怒母亲。这是昭昭天命的时代，就像美国的命运是继承这片土地，从被称作异教徒和野蛮人的人手中夺取它一样。就在那时，我认为新英格兰人真正开始越来越关注汉娜·达斯廷，将其视为他们应该纪念的那种女英雄。
You would also come across her story if you read famous American writers like Hawthorne. Or John Greenleaf Whittier or Henry David Thoreau, popular magazines, newspapers, essay collections, children's books, paintings. In the 1800s, Hannah Dustin was a household name. Johnny Appleseed, Davey Crockett, Hannah Dustin. But with each retelling of the story, something happened. People changed the narrative to suit their purposes. It becomes a moral problem for Americans that had a dust-and-killed children, especially
在 19 世纪中叶，当头条新闻大肆报道西部战争时，东北部如雨后春笋般涌现出各种纪念碑。当岛上的纪念碑于 1874 年建造时，现场有一千人出席。再次强调，这是美国有史以来为女性建造的第一座纪念碑；但当 1900 年左右印第安战争平息时，汉娜·达斯廷再次淡出全国聚光灯。但新英格兰的一部分人仍然坚守着她的故事。1905 年，汉娜·达斯廷的后代成立了达斯廷家族协会。
since they weren't just children, they were sleeping children. Writer's omitted details embellished others and sometimes just made things up. They completely left out the children she killed, replacing them with warriors, that abanaki child that escaped, the writers said Dustin spared him intentionally, which there's no evidence of. Most writers depicted Hannah Dustin as a sympathetic heroine, this outraged mother seeking a justifiable revenge. This was the era of manifest destiny, as in it is America's destiny to inherit the land, to seize it from people dubbed Heathens and savages. That's when I think New Englanders really started focusing on hand-and-dust and more and
他们可以说是用纪念巨石和磨盘在黑弗里尔的土地上纪念她，地点包括她独木舟靠岸的地方以及她被埋葬的地方对面。显然，他们在她转头回望、认为印第安人可能会在回家的路上跟踪她的某个地方竖立了一个纪念碑。然后一直到 20 世纪中叶，又出现了一整套以那些岩石和雕像命名的事物，疗养院、学校、街道。随着时间推移，命名热潮逐渐消退，但名字本身以及达斯廷家族却留了下来。
more as the kind of heroin they should commemorate. In the mid-1800s, as headlines screamed about the wars in the West, monuments sprung up in the Northeast. When the monument on the island was built in 1874, there were a thousand people present. Again, it was the first monument ever built to a woman in the U.S. but when the Indian wars died down around 1900, Hannah Dustin dropped out of the National Spotlight again. But a subset of New Englanders held on to her story. In 1905, Hannah Dustin's descendants created the Dustin Family Association.
嗯，我叫小塞德里克·H·达斯廷（Cedric H. Dustin, Jr.）。我是汉娜的第 10 代子孙。那么，这会使她成为我的第八代曾祖母吗？我不确定。我只是没数过。差不多吧，是的。
They sort of littered the landscape of Haverl with memorial boulders and millstones in her honor at sites where she landed her canoe across from where she was buried. Apparently, they put one up at one place where she turned around and looked back thinking that Indians might be following her on her way home. Then all the way into the mid-1900s, there was a whole other layer of things named after those rocks and statues, a nursing home, a school, streets. Over time the namings peed her out, but the names themselves stuck and so did the Dustin family. Well, my name is Cedric H. Dustin, Jr. I'm the 10th generation from Hannah.
塞德里克是达斯廷家族协会的副会长兼前会长。他 88 岁了，从童年起就知道汉娜·达斯廷的事。对塞德里克来说，汉娜是一位女英雄。她关心她自己的生命以及我们同伴的生命。因此，我认为她是一个了不起的女士，能想出那样的计划并做出她所做的事。但基本上，我认为这是为了自我保护。
So, would that make her my eighth grade grandmother? I'm not sure. I just haven't counted. Something like that, yeah. Cedric is the vice president and formally the president of the Dustin Family Association. He's 88 and he's known about Hannah Dustin since he was a boy. To Cedric, Hannah was a heroine. She was concerned about her own life and those of us companions. And as such, I thought she was quite a lady to hatch the planet she did and do the thing she did.
为了澄清一件事，达斯廷家族协会不再游说修建雕像了。他们主要花时间追溯家谱，并在每年夏天聚在一起举办烧烤活动。塞德里克·达斯廷说，他理解为什么有些人不是他这位隔了八代的祖母的超级粉丝。但他对雕像和岛屿年久失修感到失望。汉娜的鼻子被步枪打掉了。上面有涂鸦，草坪已经好几年没修剪了。当我年轻的时候，我可以去那里把整片草都割了，但现在年龄不允许我这么做。但我认为新罕布什尔州应该好好利用这样一个事实，即他们的领地内拥有这个国家有史以来为女性建立的第一座雕像。或许应该在该地点竖立一个新的标志来表明这一点，而不是他们现在用来表明那个岛上发生的事迹的标志。
But basically, I think this for self-preservation. Just to make something clear, the Dustin Family Association isn't lobbying for statues anymore. They mostly spend time tracing their lineage and they get together for a barbecue every summer. And Cedric Dustin says he understands why some aren't such a big fan of his grandmother, eight generations removed. But he has disappointed the statue and the island are in disrepair. Hannah's nose was shot off of the rifle. There's graffiti and the grass hasn't been mowed in years. When I was a young man I could have gone up there and cut the whole thing, but right now age won't let me do that. But I think the stain onshire should make good use of the fact that they have in their
所以这就是那个岛，对吧？这就是那个岛。我和一个说自己已经多年不去那里的人一起回到了那个有 30 英尺高的汉娜·达斯廷纪念碑的岛上。她看起来一点也不像英雄。她看起来更像是一个机会主义者，一个愤怒的机会主义者，回去之后还吹嘘此事，然后历史就成了历史。
confines the first statue ever erected to a woman in this country. Perhaps a new science should be put at that location indicating that as opposed to the sign that they are now indicating the deeds that happened on that island. So this is the island, huh? This is the island. I went back to the island with the 30-foot tall Hanodustin monument. With someone who says he's avoided going out there for years. She doesn't look very heroic. She looks more like an opportunist, angry opportunist that went
我是保罗。我是保罗·普利奥（Paul Puglio），我是萨加莫尔（Saga Mall），大致翻译过来就是科索克（Kosok）彭托考克·阿纳基（Pentocook Abnaki）人最高委员会的首席发言人。保罗不相信科顿·马瑟对这个故事的说法。那个关于阿纳基人把达斯廷新生婴儿往树上砸的说法。他说这与其他时代的被俘故事不符。我们有许许多多被俘者的记录说，被阿纳基人抓走并不是死刑。许多人去了加拿大，有些人回来了。保罗认为汉娜的俘虏可能对她很好。
back and then bragged about it, and then history has become history. This is Paul. I'm Paul Puglio, I'm the Saga Mall, which is roughly translated the principal speaker of the Grand Council of the Kosok being of the Pentecostal Kinnabnaki people. Paul doesn't buy cotton mathers version of the Kosok being of the Pentecostal Abnaki people. Paul doesn't buy cotton mathers version of the story. The one with the Abnaki smashed Dustin's newborn baby against the tree. He says it doesn't mesh with other captivity stories of the era. We have many, many accounts of captives saying that
嗯，大概和被俘虏时能受到的待遇一样好。他说阿纳基人非常敬重儿童，所以像科顿·马瑟的故事中所描绘的那样，一个战士把婴儿往树上砸的想法在他看来是不太可能的。不可能知道婴儿是如何被杀害的，也不知道汉娜·达斯廷是如何被她的看守对待的。我犹豫是否要从我 21 世纪的视角去评判她为了逃跑而应该或不应该做什么。但很明显，汉娜·达斯廷的故事很复杂。
being taken by the Abnaki was not a death sentence. Many went to Canada, someone who were treated back. Paul thinks Hannah's captives were probably treating her well. Well, presumably as well as one can be treated in captivity. And he says Abnaqi's revered children, so the idea of a warrior bashing a baby against a tree as cotton math or story portrays sounds unlikely to him. It's impossible to know how the baby was killed
保罗认为关于她的纪念碑应该被遗忘。我的意思是，我真的认为这座纪念碑不应该以任何方式被保存。就让它这样吧，它会在这里持续几千年，所以这里很不幸。它不会消失。这就是现在的问题。
or how Hannah Dustin was treated by her captors. And I hesitate to judge from my 21st century vantage point what she should or shouldn't have done in order to make her escape. But it's clear that the Hannah Dustin story is complicated. Paul thinks the monument to her should just be forgotten. I mean, I really don't think this monument should be preserved in any way. Just let it, it's gonna last here for millennia, so it's unfortunate here.
汉娜·达斯廷纪念碑——岛上的那座和其他所有的纪念碑——大多是位于偏僻地方逐渐褪色的遗迹。但每隔几年，一些政客、历史爱好者或美洲原住民就会指着其中一座说，把它拆了吧，或者把它清理干净。每一次，人们都在争论：她是一个女英雄？还是一个恶棍？同样的事情一遍又一遍地上演。就在过去几个月里，关于这座纪念碑的讨论又死灰复燃了。
It's not going away. And that's the problem now. The Hanodustin monuments, the one on the island and all the others, are mostly fading relics and out-of-the-way places. But every few years, some politician or history buff or Native American points to one and says, tear this thing down or clean this thing up. And every time, people argue, is she a heroine? Or is she a villain? The same thing over and over and over. Just in the last couple months, there's been renewed talk about the monument.
人们建议竖立更多的牌匾来展示阿纳基人的历史，或者将名字从“汉娜·达斯廷纪念州立历史遗址”更改为“昆图库克岛州立历史遗址”。但即使是像清理纪念碑上的涂鸦或修剪草坪这样的小事，也可以被视为在表态：汉娜·达斯廷到底配不配拥有一座纪念碑，她究竟是英雄还是恶棍。在我们离开这个岛之前，保罗·普利奥说他想私下做一件事。
People are suggesting putting up additional plaques that show the Appanaki history, or changing the name from the Hannah Dustin Memorial State Historic Site to the Kuntukuk Island State Historic Site. But even something as small as cleaning up graffiti on the monument, or mowing the grounds, could be seen as taking a stance about whether Hannah Dustin deserved a monument in the first place, about whether she was actually a hero or villain. Before we left the island, Paul Puglio said there was something he wanted to do off the record.
当然，不录音吗？好的。他掏出一个鼓和一些烟草。他在纪念碑周围踱步了两次。有一次他在雕像的四个面撒了一点烟草。另一次他敲击着鼓并唱着歌。他不想让我录下这个仪式，但他事后谈到了这件事。我们不想忘记过去的祖先。所以我们唱了一首致敬的歌，并献上了烟草，以净化我们在那里走动的场地。
Sure, no recording? Okay. He pulled out a drum and some tobacco. He paced around the monument twice. One time he scattered a little tobacco on four sides of the statue. The other time he beat the drum and sang. He didn't want me to record the ceremony,
这样做会给你带来任何宽慰或满足感吗？嗯，这是恰当的做法，你知道的，只是向大地之母（Earth Movative）请求，你知道的，以大地之母的名义尊重她，接受并理解这一切，以此作为现在的某种终结。
but he talked about it afterwards. We don't want to forget our ancestors of the past. So we did a little honoring song and we made an offering of tobacco to kind of purify the grounds where we were walking around there. And does it provide you with any relief or satisfaction to do that? Well, it's what is appropriate, you know, just asking Earth Movative, you know, oning her if Movato, taking back and understanding with this kind of closure of the end now.
精神上的了结，除此之外别无他求。在没有关于如何将保罗的祖先纳入这段历史的任何公开决定的情况下，这个私人仪式只能勉强算数了。目前，这座雕像带着被射掉的鼻子和巨大而 haunting 的牌匾，依然遭到忽视和 crumbling，这实际上可能是今天我们对汉娜·达斯廷复杂情感的最准确象征：对她曾经是谁感到矛盾，却又还没准备好彻底放手。1697年3月15日、30日，战吼、战斧、柴捆和杀婴事件发生在……99% Invisible 本周由杰克·罗特利科与凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、埃弗里·特鲁布曼（Avery Troubleman）以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，办公室设在加利福尼亚州美丽的老金山市中心，距离第 12 街和百老汇公交车站仅几步之遥。
Spiritual closure, if nothing else, in lieu of any public decision on how to include Paul's ancestors in this history, this private ceremony will have to be enough. For now, the statue, with her shot off nose and big, haunting plaque, remains neglected and crumbling, which actually is probably the most accurate symbol of how we feel about Hannah Dust in today, ambivalent about who she was, but not quite ready to let her go. March 15th, 30th, 1697, the Warhoop Tomahawk, a faggot and infanticides were at 99% Invisible What's Produced This Week by Jack Roteliko with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced the offices
你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Tumblr 上探索更多关于这个节目的内容，并与我们这些制作人以及像你一样的粉丝互动。但如果你想看到鼻子被射掉的汉娜·达斯廷雕像，可以访问 99pi.org。你现在听到的音乐来自 99PI 的最爱奥克·阿库米（Ok Akumi）。他现在有一张非常棒的新专辑发行。当它在背景中播放时，奥克·阿库米的音乐让我们的节目变得更好，同样的魔力也可以在你的日常生活中发挥作用。
of Arxite just steps away from the 12th and Broadway bar stop in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can explore more and more about this show and interact with those of us who make it and fans just like you on Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr. But if you want to see the statue of Hannah Dustin with her no-shot off, that is at 99pi.org. The music you're listening to right now is by 99PI favorite Ok Akumi. He has a fantastic new album out right now. When it plays in the background, Ok Akumi's music makes our show so much better and that same magic can work in your everyday life.
相信我，它管用。访问 Ok Akumi.com 或点击我们网站 99pi.org 上的链接。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Trust me, it works. Go to Ok Akumi.com or follow the links on our website, 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，这很有效。访问 Ok Akumi.com 或点击我们网站 99pi.org 上的链接。Radio tapio，来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。